What I'd like to do, and [LAUGH] I'm
guessing maybe you don't want me to,
but I'm going to try to do it anyway,
is go through the argument as to
why policy duration actually works.
I think ultimately it's not that bad,
but
we're going to [LAUGH] slog through it.
And so, one of the things we're going to
need is the ability to compare policies
to each other, and
value functions to each other, and so,
we're going to introduce
the concept of domination.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> [LAUGH] So,
this is what domination [LAUGH]
means in the context of policies.
We're going to say that policy one
dominates policy two if it's the case
that for all states the value of
that policy, at that state for
policy one, is bigger than or equal to
the value at that state for policy two.
So, it could be that there's some
policies where policy one does better in
one state, policy two does
better in another state, but
if it dominates it, policy one
has to do no worse in any state.
And in fact, we're going to
say we have strict domination.
[NOISE] If it's the case that
>> [LAUGH]
>> policy one dominates policy two, and
there's some state for
which it's actually strictly better,
it's not equality.
And just for fun, we'll also introduce
the concept of epsilon optimal policies.
So, a policy is epsilon optimal if it's
the case that the value function for
that policy is epsilon close
to the value function for
the optimal policy at all states.
And so what this does is it gives
us a concept of bounding loss or
bounding regret.
So, we'll say that a policy is nearly
optimal if the amount that it loses,
essentially, per time
step is very small.
>> Okay.
So, by the way, does this mean that if
policy one dominates policy two, but
does not strictly dominate it, they
must have the same value everywhere?
>> Yeah, that's right.
They'd have to have- it
would never be greater than,
it would always be greater than or equal
to, which means it's always equal to.
So, two policies that,
well, what you said.
>> Oh, okay, good.
Well, as long as it's what I said.